here is a hard ratio question Alice and
Olivia share some sweets in the ratio
7-3 Alice gives three sweets to Olivia
and now the ratio is five to three how
many sweets did each have initially
let's work this out step by step the
initial ratio is seven to three so Alice
had seven X and Olivia had 3x
then Alice gives three sweets to Olivia
meaning Alice ends up with 7x minus
three and Olivia ends up with three X
plus three
this leads to the ratio of five to three
so five over three is equal to the ratio
of these numbers
we can then solve this equation by cross
multiplying
we then will distribute group like terms
and solve that X is equal to four
how many sweets did each have initially
Alice had 7x and Olivia had 3x and that
works out to Alice Heming 28 and Olivia
having 12.